[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
monday june 27th i'm julie chang for the
wall street journal filling in for zoe
thomas
virtual reality is popular for games and
fitness it's also becoming more popular
in senior communities rendevor is one vr
company whose platform is increasingly
being used to help seniors who might be
struggling rendezvous co-founder and ceo
kyle rand says some have used the
company's vr platform to travel back to
childhood streets connect with loved
ones who are physically far away and
more and he says that's helped improve
their mental health
at the wall street journal's recent
future of everything festival rand spoke
with wsj personal tech columnist nicole
nguyen about how virtual reality can and
is being used to combat loneliness in
senior living communities here are
highlights from their conversation so
when people who are skeptical of virtual
reality think of vr i think they think
of a wally style future where you're
floating around holding your giant soda
with a screen strapped to your face
completely ignorant of everything that's
happening around you but your company is
working on a very different take than
that it's a virtual reality enabled
therapy and wellness platform i believe
um can you tell us a little bit more
about what that therapy entails and and
the role vr has in it yeah it's such an
interesting
perspective a lot of people so we're
about to turn six years old our company
around ever
so six years ago vr was still very new
and we came up with this idea of using
it for older adults to empower a better
lifestyle for them a lot of people
thought oh this is just escapism right
the ability to put on a headset and
just be anywhere else other than a
senior living community but really what
we're doing is we've designed this
platform that enables people to put
these headsets on and they can go
anywhere in the world they can stand on
top of the eiffel tower they can go on a
hot air balloon ride they can go back to
their childhood home and stay in front
of their childhood home again for the
first time
and
they do it together so really it's a
social experience platform where people
are able to spend time doing real world
things exploring the world and then
building relationships as a result of it
how are you structuring these platforms
um what if you don't want to visit your
childhood home for example uh how do you
know what content to serve interestingly
enough we've done demos for the past six
years like every single age group if i
tell someone they can go anywhere in the
world nine times out of ten they're
gonna say bring me home
especially if they're very far away from
home and so it's a really meaningful
meaningful location but our approach to
content creation and experience delivery
is if they're like
when you think about the aging process
what happens day in and day out is your
world starts to shrink right and what we
can do in vr is we can open up those
doors and
the diversity of the aging demographic
is so wide that somebody might want to
go to paris somebody might want to go to
israel somebody might want to spend like
my grandfather when i first did a
session with him we went on a hot air
balloon ride we went swimming with
dolphins we
we went on a roller coaster ride and
then i brought him back to his home in
long island he still lives in long
island so it was like i don't know 20
miles away and then we spent two hours
we were up until two in the morning
exploring the streets of the areas that
he grew up in and like that's what he
leaned into because that's what's so
significant for him
and for this demographic
when you create a connection to the
place that you're visiting the
experience that you're having it opens
up the floor for communication that's
really positive that oftentimes can be
really hard to find before the session
we were talking about um your new puppy
your new dog dad but also that you have
a puppy agenda um as it relates to
content that's on this platform yes so
one of the very first things that we
launched was a room full of golden
retriever puppies and golden lab puppies
and i actually have an amazing story so
that same community that first started
uh we were doing this demonstration
before we started working with them and
we had like this whole group of
residents everybody was experiencing vr
they're having a great time and about
halfway in they wheeled in a woman and
her name was mickey and her caregiver
pulled me aside i was like i need you to
understand her story and
he was like this woman was one of the
first people to move into our community
she's been with us since day one and she
always has had a smile on her face like
she knows everyone by name she's the
first person to say hi to you in the
morning she's just like this beacon of
light in our community and then two
months
prior to that she had been diagnosed
with early stage dementia and she was
moved upstairs into the locked memory
care floor
and what happened was she had her first
symptom was expressive aphasia so she
actually lost her ability to communicate
so she went for me this outgoing
boisterous woman to all of a sudden not
being able
to talk and so what we did was we
brought her into that room full of
puppies
and it was like this like a light switch
turned right back on this huge smile
comes across her face she like started
calling out to the puppies like kissing
at them and like virtual rooms
a virtual room full of puppies very
important and just got so engaged and so
excited and she actually was talking to
the dogs and the most amazing thing
happened at the end of the session she
took that headset off and she kept
talking
and she actually followed me and my
co-founder out of the building holding
onto my co-founder's arm and she was
talking about how we needed to use this
technology for children and to use it
within school systems because it would
be amazing to learn through vr if you
think about that what happened was after
just a 30 minute session in vr she went
from three months of not talking at all
to pitching us business ideas so content
aside there's a lot that needs to be
improved in the hardware itself you use
a third party virtual reality headset
correct correct
things like battery life and the weight
of the headset
and
especially when it comes to
accessibility i have a left eye that's
much worse than my right eye so when i
use vr i feel nauseous i can't wear it
for a long time and i imagine that a lot
of your audience is visually impaired or
has some other sort of a similar need
how are you working around that yeah
it's interesting i think we're really
just starting to learn about the
implications for visual impairments i
think if you if it's laterally different
that's that's something we haven't seen
or tested yet but one of the most
interesting things we've seen is people
with glaucoma and with macular
degeneration
vr is actually one of their favorite
things and
the the research isn't there yet you
know it's easy to guess that the reason
they're able to actually see in vr is
because the screen is so close and so
their fovea like really widens but i
think we're really as we look to the
future you know the hardware has really
done amazing things in the past couple
of years there's a lot of places to go
there's a lot of research to be done to
understand how it works with a variety
of different conditions if the audience
has questions feel free to raise their
hands
and and ask
is the content is it cg based or video
based so it's a combination honestly
it's a combination of video based
experiences honestly video or sorry
photo based experiences like 360 photos
and fully rendered
application environments and
interestingly a lot of people think that
360 videos are where most people would
lean in but we have we have analytics
that show exactly what people are doing
and we see that the highest adoption the
largest amount of time spent in vr is
actually on 360 imagery where people are
able to be there and just spend a lot of
time there and i think you know there's
a lot that we could talk about there but
i think one of the big reasons is that
if you're in a 360 video experience you
are limited to the constraints of what
is in that video versus if you're in a
still environment you're going to spend
a lot of time just exploring the
environment looking and talking about
the things that are happening and it
creates so much opportunity for a
conversation to happen in those
experiences thank you so much for
joining us thank you nicole thank you
all thank you everybody
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want to listen to the
full talk check out the link in our show
notes and as always for more tech
stories you can go to our website
wsj.com
i'm julie chang for the wall street
journal thanks for listening
[Music]
you